hey guys welcome to the room and report
I'm Dave Rubin we are doing a one-on-one
this week we have a guy who needs no
introduction and truly a living legend
how about that intro a dead legend
better than a dead legend Larry King
welcome to the Reuben report thank you
David great to be with you always have
loved having you on my show and it's
great to return the compliment
I appreciate that actually the first
time I was on your show I had a sweating
fit when we did that Republican National
Convention and you took that you told me
I was sweating more than Albert Brooks
in broadcast news which is truly one of
the greatest moments in my career
broadcast news is one of this all-time
great movies I think great great movie
about the media well for everything we
do right and for me especially because I
saw that movie
two weeks after quintuple bypass surgery
Wow and I sat next to Mike Wallace
everyone said Diane so the hole the hole
in crowd in New York and my surgery was
in New York so we all attended that
filming everybody loved it yeah well
let's start with a little bit about the
media so you have been around the media
for basically your whole life and at
least 57 years 57 years but who's
counting what what do you think are the
biggest changes in the way the media
landscape has you know you're you're
doing an online show now we're doing it
making changes one technical in that
when I started there was a radio and
television and landlines and telephone
lines and then came satellites and now
we have internet and all the
technological end has been incredible
and that has led to 500 channels and
anything goes and you know when Jackie
Gleason went off the air he had 33
million viewers there was no show that
that approaches 20 million viewers so
the pie is cut up in many many slices
and we all have a little piece of a
slice a piece of pie rather sore and I
left CNN I thought I could retire and
then Along Came Carlos lemon the
internet Nam on the internet every day
and who knows who knows what's next the
delivery system
now the basic hasn't changed this one on
one
has not changed we still need the human
being it has that hasn't changed the
method of delivery has changed are we
losing something with the one-on-one I
mean really what your trademark is this
what we're doing right now we don't get
that in a way that we used to sadly
enough because it's a it's better eat it
up spit it out go to the next thing you
know cause there's something grab
something jump on it stay bang it out
then go whatever was next and a lot of
it leads to I mean some of it is absurd
Addie mm-hmm I miss in-depth interviews
you don't see much of that anymore on on
cable television
you know it's going away everywhere and
I said do you think it's just a function
of Technology or is there actually
something else go there something about
humans and the way we're evolving is
about humans or or about management or
about the people running networks now or
we call them as suits mm-hmm they didn't
come up the broadcast their accountants
they're a pill pushers you know they
they work with what this works that does
work keep business doesn't work you know
classic example was at my old Network
CNN which was I loved every day of my
twenty five and a half years there I did
a lot for them they did a lot for me it
was a great career Ted Turner was the
best person I've worked for but I didn't
speak to admit speak with Ted recently
but if he saw what was going on now for
example the airplane yeah for example
they covered that 24 hours a day they
missed in you had the Russians gone into
Ukraine the other day in one day I
watched the show and said I'll forget
the show but they never mentioned other
news it was airplane oh yeah and the
airplane was all conjecture we think it
landed here we might have gone here with
you since day two they made that advance
nothing in that story but conjecture it
was breaking supposition breaking
speculation it was never breaking news
so if you were there now I don't know
what but here oh I'd have insisted
let's do other things now they would
have said we got a tremendous audience
then well they're the network I would
have gone off
there's nothing I could do is to break
it I would have tried to urge for
example the other day while CNN and some
other cable news networks I'm sure we're
doing airplane coast-to-coast
wire-to-wire ten people in Washington
were killed in a mudslide there were
three Americans on that plane ten
Americans died in a mudslide in
Washington no coverage the g8 conference
in Russia was cancelled rescheduled for
Belgium with Russia left out no mention
an enormous enormous occurrence in
Houston of an oil slick that destroyed
hundreds and hundreds of miles of water
not covered the President of the United
States is in the Netherlands he's
talking to China about trying to get
China to at least stay neutral in the
Russian situation no coverage that is
abysmal so who do we blame for this
because I I'm with you everybody feels
this but is it is it a matter of ratings
versus ladies versus logic yeah so why
do so we but the and the reason that
that doesn't work is all right you get
super ratings and you think advertisers
don't know that these ratings are based
on a hyped up thing okay so what happens
after the incident is over whenever it
ends and you got to decide when does
that end when is the public lose
interest then you go back to your other
program you sink down again the
advertisers ain't gonna buy it for the
next six months based on that two-week
jump because they all know what it was
like buying I'm gonna buy CBS I'm gonna
buy NBC for a year because boy the
Superbowl did great Super Bowl the great
I better buy NBC next Tuesday no no
there's none other what the other but
that's let's think and it's it's sad to
me so what do we do to change this so
you for example you're on or a TV now
which is an online news network we here
at the Young Turks we're an online news
network I firmly believe that this is
the future of news so as you can we
reach three million people in February
you do that you know it'll grow yeah in
little bro total all balanced yeah but I
predicting the future in this business
is even possible
yeah there is that when I started in
radio in Miami in 1957 the University of
Miami owned an FM station and FM was
considered background music I listen to
FM right they gave that station through
the University of Miami the University
of Miami latest solarization which
became the number one powerhouse station
in Miami if you de said in 1957
hey FM was gonna really take off
frequency much time on you're kidding
so I i I've learned not to predict right
and it did okay for about the last 50
years or so they've been wrong so if we
can't predict it what what do you make
of the general partisan nature of news
because to me that's been the thing in
the last 10 years that we really use it
that's one thing about CNN that has CNN
has stayed in the middle which is a
tough place to be yeah in a way because
everyone is so partisan and is so are
you cnn's credit I'm happy that they
have stayed not they've strayed a little
sometimes you'll see opinions mm-hmm
I don't see how I growing by some I
always thought that my opinion as an
interview it didn't count but I was
there to learn from what the guests
thought I left my ego at the door the
name my show was and then the name of
the show was Larry King Live so I'll be
back soon I know I I saw was who what
where when why and the guest counted on
a lot of these shows the guest is a prop
for the host the host use the word Isle
is irrelevant
I don't care what the host things I care
what the if I never if I get a lawyer on
I don't know more law than a lawyer I
never voted in the Senate I never
carried a gun as weapon in war
I never performed an operation how could
I know more about medicine than a doc
yeah you know so I might have my
personal opinions on things but I
certainly value the guests and what that
guest has to say I may not agree with it
so let it come through me as a conduit
yeah I think that's lost so when you had
moments that you really disagreed with
someone on air this part was then in
moral issues yeah to me that the hardest
part was in the race of a racial issue
when I had to interview George Wallace
the Governor of Alabama nearly he
changed significantly
that was tough and sometimes I did get
into arguments but I found that in those
moral areas when I got into an argument
what happened was it may have seemed
exciting but you didn't learn anything
it was just two people yelling at each
other and that's effective but you know
ratings are Jackie Gleason was a mentor
of mine and a great man and Jackie told
me something you know Palio's you say
pal I could put intercourse on
television on CBS Tuesday night for
three hours I'm gonna wipe you up you
might as well not even go anywhere else
I own America right that's not talent
right and that was before Lucy could
even put the beds together right of
course if you could titillate this the
mind of people an appeal to their prey
and interest I'm gonna own the night
yeah takes no talent so let's talk a
little bit about politicians then
speaking of ratings and the ability to
get someone to tell the truth they often
I now see these interview shows and
politicians have a way of no matter what
you as the interviewer ask they answer a
completely different question and and
they shamelessly do it how do you use or
directly honest gets shunted aside when
it cook a very Goldwater and George
McGovern were two classic examples I've
interviewed them both many times and
both passed on now Barry go on George
McGovern had no cut off between the
brain in the mouth you guys no questions
answered right wiped out in national
elections because the public and the we
in the media say we want direct honesty
in a Weedle
Bastien if you directly honest so what
the politician tries to do is how can I
say something
the best tip anybody if you're watching
an interview show with a politician and
I guess this ask the question and the
politician says I'm glad you asked that
here's the truth he's solely not glad
yes and he has said I'm glad you asked
that so he can think of how to answer it
that will appeal to the largest common
denominator so I'm guessing you probably
heard that about four billion times in
25 years on CNN so you do the best you
can what I try to do is get at the core
things I try to ask good questions come
around in a lot of ways but on the other
hand I have a great respect for
politicians for this reason they do
something that we don't do one they
stand up and be counted and they have
what we have never had in our lives they
have a Tuesday in November where the
score goes up and we don't do that oh we
have ratings but that's sporadic right
the score goes up so I've always
respected politicians and athletes
athletes have something we don't have
won their livelihood ends when most of
our really good livelihood begins the
cheering stops when they're 40 our
cheering's in life starts at 40 pretty
much number two they have a final score
you know ain't it you lost you know we
don't have a final score yeah I didn't
lose four to three today but somebody
lost four somebody played basketball
last night I know one team scored 102
and one team scored 97 you can call all
you want the people on 97 lost they lost
so is that it right there is that the
problem with the media that we don't
score things in there is no respect
athletes because they face that yeah I
respect politicians because they get a
Tuesday in November that we don't have
so I begin with the respect for a man
who ran fro then I can
if he gets jaundiced or
off-the-beaten-track then you know you
try to I you try to learn as much as you
can all I tried
do an interviewing was learned as much
as I can when I yelled at people I never
learned anything yeah I was on your show
last week and Dennis Prager was on who's
a conservative radio host who I don't
agree with especially on the social
stuff and you've been a big supporter of
the LGBT the gay community and I could
see you were getting into it a little
bit with him but it was it was based in
respect and honesty so this burger off
he is and I like him yeah I don't agree
with him I think on the gay issue he's
way off track but he comes from a
religious bent and he asked a question
that cause you to thinking one one thing
I like I like about questions of course
when Dennis Prager said if you had two
people you're the judge someone's gonna
get this child a gay couple or a
heterosexual couple and they're equally
valued who would give the child to and I
think the correct answer you might give
it to the gay couple you buy but it
wouldn't depend on that but I can see
where he's coming from where you can
make a case for that and I like great
moral arguments like that when that
someone's presented to me because it
causes what we want to do is think we
want to progress we want to think I read
an article the other day should we be
mad at Woody Allen should we not see a
Woody Allen movie because of what he did
with supposedly his young son should we
not so the question was posed this way
and I love this suppose and I showed you
a great painting and you loved it
what a painting it captured drama and
then I told you Hitler painted it was
your opinion of the painting change it
probably would why I guess that wouldn't
be in the most purest artists sense of
it but if knowing where it came from can
you separate the art from the artists
but those are great moral questions we
ask them all the time that's the kind of
thing I like that's the kind of
give-and-take where you could have a
guest I group may not want to buy the
painting but the guest could defend get
buying the painting on its value at its
core yeah right and that's those are
great arguments that you don't see
anymore
so speaking of that do you see the the
gay movement as sort of the civil rights
I do I know our time however I went
through a lot of things you know when
you've been in business 57 years I was
in Miami when Anita Bryant yeah started
the let's be civil movement and it was
an anti-gay movement and we had a ballot
to give gays the right to open housing
and the biggest attack on that vote was
the blacks they voted 98% against it
against a bill who would have given gays
complete rights in Miami and the reason
was they said don't put us in the gay
rights category we we have a color wrong
yeah we're not gays that's completely
changed gay is a civil rights issue and
what the the people opposed to would
have to face is it's a losing war brand
you're done Cody so what about the
politicians then because these people if
they want one thing it's to remain in
power right and that's the part that I
don't change I saw George Wallace yeah
go from barring the door at the
University of Alabama not letting a
student enter to his chief of staff
being black yeah I saw it I I lived in
us when I arrived in Miami to break into
broadcasting I got off the train and the
first thing I saw was a water fountain
and said color only and I drank out of
that fountain it was good water well
then I got on a bus to go over to Miami
Beach to stay with my uncle and I sat in
the back of the bus and the bus driver
pulled over and said you have to move to
the front first the back of the bus is
for Negroes and the front of buses for
whites I couldn't believe it I was from
Brooklyn so I said my father's black be
the utter stupidity of it but IRA in
Miami a progressive City in 1957 blacks
and whites couldn't compete against each
other on the football field they could
not now missus all these teams now the
entire Mississippi basketball teams
black
alabama bears 14 is black
they're all yeah you know it's just yeah
so now we've seen that equip we have a
black president yes we'll have a gay
president yes we'll have a female person
life is changing and the politician will
have to change along with it or blues
right well you've given me a perfect
segue then to let's do a little bit of
political footballing so 2016 is coming
we've talked a little bit about it on
your show Hillary is I mean is it a
foregone conclusion as much as she wants
it she's a nominee I don't think any I
don't think Biden will run against her I
think with the promise that he'll be
Secretary of State
I think that's logical to think that it
would be a great Secretary what do you
make of the idea that we'd have these
families then you know it would be the
bushes in the question she's totally
opposed against it yeah Barbara Bush
doesn't want Jeb to run yeah you know
she says I love Barbara Bush one of my
favorite people of all time you stop
with this already
stop with the bushes and the clean mop
yeah we've had enough but isn't that how
most of America feels not you think that
we're sort of being this is just being
pushed on us again like oh now Jan and
now Hillary and then it's gonna be Malia
2024 in Chelsea 2030 or switch those two
you know you know what Americans like it
and you know why Americans like it
because John Kennedy said it best what
Americans really want is a kind king
that is leave us alone now if you could
do that as the Adams or the bushes or
had John Kennedy with the Kennedys
Robert would have been president mm-hmm
right Ted if yet maybe child didn't have
Chappaquiddick he'd oven
we'd like that it's there's in something
inside of us likes the fact that we have
this family protector it's a god-like
thing they're our protector you know and
doesn't it seem sort of backwards though
to how our country was born because we
left England because yeah so what do you
think that says about course I think
Kennedy had a right weevil we'd like to
kind King quitters you know the decision
to make just don't bother us nor don't
throw us in jail for a crime we didn't
commit
yeah don't prevent us from doing things
we want to do but
be nice yeah just be nice don't end up
citizens off to war where they're gonna
get killed unless he could really
justify just be nice kind King King well
on that note I got I got two more for
you I'm a kind king you're a kind king I
can tell I'm feeling the kindness how do
you like being on this side of the being
interviewed Peter you're sitting off the
great actor once I asked him that if you
like being if he said I love being
interviewed because it makes me think
about things I don't think about noise I
don't drive around all day interviewing
myself so it forces you to think so when
when you're asked good questions that
you've been asking good questions it
forces me to think I'd like to think
when there's stupid questions you know
then that matters a little I've had some
of those yeah the best instance that was
I was touring a book I wrote I've
written 16 books I was turning a book
and I was on the show called good
morning Dallas I could tell you right
away you can I could tell you right away
you know what the host and hostess like
Generic go set perfectly croft here and
the woman had blond hair puffed around
yeah and the woman was scheduled to
interview me and as she's asking me
quite I can see that she's reading off
the questions on a piece of paper he's
not listening to my answers and while
I'm answering it she's like fixing her
hair and the crew is living I'm
answering the questions a fourth
question was what makes a good talk-show
host and I said well I don't know about
other people I can tell she's not
listening but what helps me the most is
being in the CIA because by being in the
CIA what happens is they they get me
great guests and I can tip off spies
around the world and then she goes on to
another thing well raising children is
that yeah and you don't think she heard
a word you were saying it was yeah well
you've done something right on this side
of the table too because
I haven't looked at my notes once so I'm
feeling pretty good about this so my
final question to you is I can I can
tell the people you're 80 years old
right that's that's public have a big
that's public relations party was in
Dodger Stadium with that as big of a
thrill for you you're a baseball guy
with that big shock yeah at the same
time mister my wife pulled it off it on
how she pulled it off this said all
those people up yeah to walk into that
stadium I thought I was going to a
meeting of season ticket holders was a
logical they had a great ploy yeah they
had a letter from the Dodgers to me
season ticket holder come on Friday
night was my birthday birthday was
coming to four days later mm-hmm I
thought she was gonna do something on my
birthday night I was on Jimmy Kimmel on
my actually birthday and that was booked
a long time ago so I thought they were
taking me somewhere after Jimmy Kimmel
right that's what I thought so they
totally threw me
yeah and they had like almost 300 people
at at home plate
people who kids in uniform playing
baseball the stadium is all lit up my
thing up on the scoreboard I couldn't
believe I could I just I just I couldn't
believe it so but I can see it in your
eyes I mean baseball really is I grew up
with it it should trigger me my boys
play it
the biggest thrill I get in my life is
watching my kids yeah I was not a good
athlete a baseball fan like last
Saturday my son pitched for Notre Dame
freshman he's in Wow first one in high
school and I watched him on the mound
and he you know like there's one guy
sitting next to me says wait
that kids a ballplayer just the way
moves he's got swagger and he baseball
does a move an athlete has you can know
if the guy's a player he's a player it's
the way he comes out of the dugout the
way he handles his glove the way he
looks away any pitched shutout innings
he struck out the side in the first
inning and I'm sitting there and I'm the
Jewish term is felling yeah felling is
when you get a thrill for something else
happen to someone you care about and I
was remembering the his birth I cut the
cord
I cut that didn't do the forest get
yourself in no no okay I cut and I so
I'm born and now he's 15 years old
pitching for Notre Dame I'm a beautiful
high school field you never sort of feel
like this they put was just how could
you top that so nothing I bet did in the
eighty years nothing
top that well I think you've answered my
final question here but how I wanted to
end this was what do you think my
grandma would always say what's it all
about Alfie so what do you think
eighty years you've interviewed live
literally everybody from every walk of
life you've talked to everybody listened
to everybody now father the whole thing
what do you think it's all about at the
end of the day what do you think you
know what there was a famous Nobel Prize
winner who lived to 95 years old and he
was at a dinner table and someone said I
forget I shouldn't forget is that when
you're 80 it's not that happened to him
what do you know 95 years what do you
know and he said and I would put this as
my epitaph the only thing I know said I
don't know well on that was it all about
Alfie I don't know I asked Stephen
Hawking just was the smartest person in
the world of physicists you're the
smartest person world what don't you
know what is something you don't know
and he said women I think he's married
though isn't he yes he is I think he's
married so that of course you're married
you know exactly well on that note I
want to thank you this has truly you
name it any time I've really been an
honor for me and we'll have you back on
again you're a great guest I appreciate
that you are a great guest so you guys
can check out Larry King now and
politicking on Ora TV and on Rt and
Wow I feel like I gotta go get a drink
or something this has been pretty great
all right thanks everyone to david has
been trying done